les mesures annoncées par le premier
ministre répond elle aux besoins des
français face à la flambée de flambée
des prix du gaz de l'électricité et de
l'essence suffisant pour éviter une
nouvelle grogne place à notre décryptage
avec nous pour en parler puis si la ludo
ski etc ce gilet jaune ou bonsoir
priscilla du dos qui merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur ce plateau joseph
thouvenel secrétaire national de la cftc
bon soit également souvent à vous vous
avez certainement suivi ou peut-être
n'avait pas eu le temps vous étiez
peut-être dans la voiture pour venir ici
elle et les annonces de jean castex à
qui annonce donc le gel de la hausse du
prix du gaz ce soir celle de demain en
revanche aura bien lieu le promet
également un bouclier tarifaire pour
l'électricité ou encore un chèque
énergie 200 euros pour descendre joseph
thouvenel ça vous paraît suffisant
aujourd'hui pour les skis un peu
choquant c'est qu'on voit des échéances
et justement ça va jusqu'aux
présidentielles c'est l'impression
d'être un peu manipulé d'autant plus que
la ministre de l'ecologie barre de rab
ont pu nous dire deux jours
l'électricité augmentation sera obligé
de 12% février et ce soir le premier
ministre à yves en visant non pas du
tout ça ne sera que 4 % ou ne se parlent
pas et ça s'appelle de l'incompétence où
il nous manipulent et 4% d'augmentation
d'électricité c'est deux fois plus que
l'inflation après s'il ya un bouclier si
les prix sont régulés si le gouvernement
empêche ces hausses extraordinaire
formidable au sens étymologique du terme
serre qui font peur parce que les gens
n'ont pas les moyens il faut qu'il
réalise et même s'il ya des gestes qui
sont faits avec un chèque de 100 euros
pour quelques familles enfin quelques
familles ça touche quelques milieux
payer les plus les moins argentés mais
toute la classe moyenne 1 il ne touche
rien et pourtant ils payent plein pot et
on a de plus en plus de gens qui
effectivement l'hiver renoncent à se
chauffer ou se chauffent le moins en
moins
parce que nous n'en avons pas les moyens
et donc là l'action du gouvernement très
bien si réguler immédiatement mais aussi
il faut qu'il réfléchisse sur le long
terme pour reprendre la main parce que
ça ce sont des biens essentiels c'est
pas des biens je sais pas je vais pas au
parc d'attractions j'ai besoin de me
chauffer j'ai besoin de l'électricité
j'ai besoin de l'eau mais quand on
regarde les taxes de l'état nous dire on
va réguler c'est très bien sur
l'électricité quels sont les 34 % de
notre facture d'électricité quand on la
paye
34% en taxes diverses et variées alors
ya de la marge pour l'état et le gaz
c'est 21% quand même de taxes donc ils
peuvent dire on régule oui effectivement
il suffit de baisser les taxes priscilla
le dock ce qui est justement vous auriez
entendu vous d'autres annoncent au soir
de jean castex notamment peut-être une
baisse d'eads est apte ou vous êtes
plutôt satisfaite de ce que vous avez
entendu ce soir
louis dont soir oui effectivement c'est
toujours bien de commencer par des
mesures qui permettent de réduire c'est
ses os même mais effectivement moi je
pars toujours évidemment de la taxe
carbone et est ce que jean tu n'entends
pas c'est la suppression de cette tva on
assure la taxe terrebonne 60% de taxes
et une tva sur la taxe donc en fait
c'est une double c'est très punitive
quoi c'est vraiment et est-ce que c'est
légal déjà j'ai la question que je pose
sur le fait de mettre une tvr sur une
taxe donc pourquoi pas les jalles abolir
cette tva sur cette taxe et et réduire
considérablement le pourcentage de cet
axe est énorme c'est plus la moitié du
tarif donc je trouve ça assez assez
dommage qu'ils aient pas fait c'est un
geste là dessus contenu en plus du
démarrage de du monde quand les jets les
jeunes qui paraît effectivement de cette
incompréhension là à côté de ça je pense
qu'il faut pas oublier aussi le
phénomène de la crise sanitaire qui a
entraîné et peut-être que ça a été
intéressant pour pas mal de gens de
pouvoir travailler à distance et donc le
télétravail engendre aussi des hausses
de nos consommations d'énergie puisque
on est à domicile l'ordinateur est
allumé toute la journée et s'il fait
froid on a le chauffage en plus calmes
et toute la journée là où avant on
utilisait l'ordinateur du travail et où
on éteignait le chauffage la journée
pour justement faire des économies
toutes ces hausses laisse qu'elles sont
accompagnés par les entreprises qu'est
ce qui se passe quand aux entreprises
pour accompagner les salariés qui
travaillent à domicile il ya peut-être
aussi quelque chose à faire là dessus et
un effectivement même si ces aides
chèque énergie et autres donnent
l'impression de donner du pouvoir
d'achat le pouvoir le pouvoir d'achat
c'est le niveau de revenus qui devrait
permettre de satisfaire ses besoins
primaires or on a quand même 9 millions
et quelques de personnes qui sont sous
le seuil de pauvreté donc ces personnes
là est ce que réellement elle peut
subvenir à leurs besoins première
question et et le pouvoir d'achat c'est
à pouvoir de vivre on ne va pas
travailler toute la journée à se
fatiguer pour simplement pouvoir payer
ses factures qui ne cesse d'augmenter on
ya peut-être aussi cette volonté de
pouvoir vivre de ceux de son du fruit de
son travail alors selon le premier
ministre je précise quand même le
pouvoir d'achat des français le seul à
avoir légèrement progressé en 2020 par
rapport aux pays qui nous entourent ils
comme iso il augmentera pardon en 2021
de 1,5 pour cent je vous trouve même ça
vous inspire quoi cette remarque de jean
castex hongrois en gros c'est ce crime
est heureux ça m'inspire que j'aime bien
vérifier les chiffres du gouvernement
avec les avec les sources parce que
regarder on nous parle et là on nous
parle moins des retraites on vous
parlait beaucoup des retraites et du
difficile des retraites qui devait être
mais leur colossal il doit être de 23
milliards ça c'était les prévisions les
chiffres sur basé sur les recherches
oui enfin c'est 13 milliards terre qu'à
10 milliards comme ça qu'ils vont qui
viennent
le pouvoir d'achat tout le monde enfin
tous ceux qui vivent normalement savent
qu'il est atteint que notre pouvoir
d'achat baisse plutôt parce que les
charges et nantes parce que les charges
ceux qui payent des impôts de plus en
plus d'impôts il ya des taxes ce qui
arrive si je ne paye pas d'impôts je
paye de tva ça a été dit à juste titre
je vais le redire quand même là les
taxes divers sur l'électricité c'est 34
% de notre facture ça ne fait que
croître et embellir ça explose sur le
gaz c'est pareil et sur l'eau c'est la
même chose
et donc là on perd du pouvoir d'achat
parce que le chiffre de réflexion est
totalement fausse et regardez bien
comment est constituée l'étude sur
l'inflation et quels sont les produits
qu'il rentre pas dedans par exemple
logement n'est pas dedans le logement
c'est accessoire ça coûte pas cher sur
le jeu c'est pas calculer et pourtant je
crois savoir que le logement coûte de
plus en plus cher c'est pour ça que ces
chiffres
il ya la vie réelle et il ya la
stratégie de communication alors même si
les choses sont pas faciles même si le
gouvernement n'a pas de baguette magique
les français voulaient présenter la
réalité parce que la voir le monde
entier
le prix de l'énergie il expose pas chez
tout le monde parce qu'il ya des pays
qui sont producteurs pour qu'elle
s'expose sport après il ya des erreurs
qui ont été faites on a vu qu arrêter un
réacteur nucléaire
ça nous coûte très cher les britanniques
ont mis rond tout base et enfin car leur
énergie sur l'éolienne oui et le
problème c'est que là ils ont eut ils
ont pas eu de vent à 8
soir effectivement aujourd'hui dans une
interview que la faute notamment aux
énergies renouvelables et aux éoliennes
et il n'y a pas eu vent en europe c'est
cet hommage avec les pas dire que faut
pas aller sur les énergies renouvelables
mais il faut que la transition soit fait
intelligemment c'est à dire que quand on
arrête quelque chose c'est parce que
l'on à leur emplacement mais pour le
moment elle n'a pas apprécié la le dos
qui vous on se souvient vous aviez lancé
le mouvement des gilet jaune avec une
pétition d'ailleurs sur l'augmentation
du prix de l'essence qui lui aussi est
faramineux ça atteint des records en ce
moment jean cassaigne d'ailleurs nous
nous rappelle ce soir que le chèque
énergie a été instaurée sous le
quinquennat à la suite du mouvement des
gilet jaune si les mesures ne sont pas
suffisantes le gouvernement est prêt
justement à revoir ce chèque à la hausse
vous avez l'impression d'avoir été
entendus
non de tout à l'heure je vous parlais je
disais que la proportion énorme de cette
taxation éclaté vers et et pèse encore
il ya aussi ce sujet d'inégalités de
l'application de cette taxe où tout le
monde n'est pas logé à la même enseigne
et où on pensait bien que
l'automobiliste est le plus gros
pollueurs il en fait partie mais pas que
et donc à quel moment on répartit cette
charge
punitive sur les autres pollueurs à on a
aussi en fait même sur cet axe là haut
ou sur les autres taxes sur les produits
de première nécessité on n'a pas de lien
au moyen des personnes qui qui paie ses
taxes cela veut dire à l'époque la taxe
n'est pas indexé au niveau de revenu des
gens et aussi au niveau d'alternative
présents sur le territoire parce que la
pétition à questionner ça aussi avisé
vous augmenter les taxes sur le
carburant notamment en disant qu'il
fallait qu'on puisse altérer nos modes
de transport de mode de déplacement or
dans certaines zones et c'est toujours
le cas aujourd'hui c'est à dire c'était
déjà dénoncé à un moment par les
mouvements qui m'a et autres s'étaient
dénoncés dans le cas du mouvement des
jeunes à travers la pétition aujourd'hui
avec on est presque à une fin de
quinquennat est ce que des alternatives
de transport ont été mises en place dans
certains territoires qui dans ce cas
dans ce cas là leur permettrait de leur
permettrait de ne pas prendre leur
véhicule parce que du coup on a des
personnes qui sont qui ont des
alternatives dans certains territoires
qui vont payer cette taxe qui va
continuer d'augmenter et d'autres qui
n'ont toujours pas d'alternative
aujourd'hui mais qui vont aussi subir la
hausse de cette taxe donc en fait c'est
très fier très inégalement répartie cet
axonais ce sont les emplois indirects
mais sont absolument pas indexé sur le
revenu et donc on a en plus une nouvelle
réforme sur le chômage qui entre en
vigueur ou l'unedic nous annonce que en
moyenne
un plus d'un million je crois que c'est
un million de points 15 de français qui
touche ces indemnités qui ne qui verront
diminuer leur indemnité de 10 7% et
c'est encore énorme donc je dire j'ai
l'impression que c'est le chat qui se
mord la queue on met un pansement avec
ces chèques énergie mais par ailleurs on
fait pas ce qu'il faut pour réellement
donné du vrai pouvoir pas d'achat mais
pouvoir de vivre dignement sans la
société joseph à tout venant sur cette
question justement du prix de l'essence
même chose trop de taxes
je pense est clair moi j'ai la chance
d'habiter en banlieue parisienne donc
d'avoir des transports en commun mais
combien de millions de personnes n'ont
pas le choix doivent utiliser leur
véhicule pour aller au travail pour
amener les enfants à l'école pour aller
à la poste qui n'existe plus pour aller
voir je ne sais trop quel service qui a
été déplacé et quand on voit le prix
mais je connais je connais des gens qui
met 15 euros par 15 euros parce qu'ils
n'ont pas les moyens de faire le plein
et 15 euros aujourd'hui c'est encore
beaucoup moins dans leur voiture que ce
qui mettait hier donc le problème il est
absolument pas résolu le problème il y
règne enfin il faut prendre conscience
que des millions de personnes souffrent
c'est c'est pas des gens qu'on entend
beaucoup on a entendu ce léger les jours
sur le gilet jaune moi je n'aime pas du
tout l'image qui a été donnée transmis
par quelques par les black blocs qui
sont emparés a sacrément les liaisons ne
sais pas ça les gène jones et des braves
gens désespérés
quand on dit on en a ras-le-bol on n'a
plus les moyens et on se met sur les
ronds-points pour dire il y en a
ras-le-bol mais ces gilets jaunes à moi
je suis entièrement avec eux parce
qu'ils ont raison quand on voit leurs
difficultés quotidiennes de vie ya le
chauffage ya les sens mais à tout le
reste des transports qui ne sont plus là
les transports collectifs la poste qui
n'est pas là les villages qui se
désertifient ça c'est la réalité alors
ça peut pas se régler d'un coup de
baguette magique encore une fois mais je
vois pas les grands efforts qui sont
faits pour aider ces gens et puis aider
ces gens ça passe pour ceux qui
travaillent la revalorisation des
salaires les plus bas parce qu'en france
les salaires sont bas notamment des
professions difficile d'éprouver toutes
les professions qui s'occupe de la
personne c'est très peu payés la
restauration l'hôtellerie le
dans le bâtiment etc etc là il ya un
véritable travail à faire parce que
qu'on aille pas me dire que c'est la
concurrence internationale qui fait que
les salaires sont bas pour les
caissières de supermarché où les
salaires sont bas de région du bâtiment
chez nous parce que ça ça se délocalise
pas alors là on pourrait faire et on
doit faire des efforts et s'apprécient
la q2 ce qui vous pensez qu'on va
échapper justement à ce mouvement un
nouveau mouvement des gilets jaunes
avec ce qu'on vient d'évoquer
j'ai envie de dire que pas mal de choses
dans l énoncé des revendications qui
vont dans le sens de ce qu'on vient
débloquer ce soir par exemple avait déjà
été transmis au gouvernement à travers
le ministre de la transition écologique
de l'époque d'autres ministres ont été
rencontrés entre temps beaucoup de
députés auront été rencontré les
sénateurs je pense que globalement avec
en plus ses associations les
organisations syndicales mêmes et
d'autres d'autres organismes qui se
battent au quotidien pour notamment
comme attaque par exemple ont déjà
transmis un certain nombre de projets
qui visent à réduire les inégalités
sociales or j'ai pas l'impression que ça
que ça change grand chose et on voit des
personnes qui ont manifesté au sein du
mouvement des gilets jaunes qui se
manifestent toujours à travers d'autres
d'autres mouvements qui oeuvre pour la
justice sociale et j'ai l'impression que
c'est un peu une veille une veille de la
population qui dit on en a ras-le-bol et
qu'elle sera toujours présente peut-être
pas de l'ampleur quoi qu'on a connus
mais mais selon moi il y aura toujours
une manière uno de se manifester y avait
beaucoup de gens qui sont manifestés sur
les réseaux sociaux notamment pendant la
crise parce que c'était un des moyens de
communication les puissants évidemment à
ce moment là mais voilà je sais pas si
ça prendre comme ça a pris avant mais je
pense que beaucoup de choses ont été
déjà dénoncé à travers ce mouvement
pendant sur la durée en plus c'est une
durée assez inédite et inattendue et en
plus avec une intensité qui a trouvé en
face à une violence policière qui a
laissé des personnes sont membres et
notamment beaucoup des borniers alors vu
le contexte d'un pouvoir d'achat
évidemment s'apprête à être un enjeu
très fort de cette campagne
présidentielle certains candidats ont
d'ailleurs déjà fait des propositions
c'est le cas de marine le pen au
rassemblement national mais aussi de
jean luc mélenchon pour la france
insoumise
on va agir sur l'essence le gaz
l'électricité le prix des péages et la
redevance il y a comme ça toute une
série de mesures qui permettront de
rester tu es 150 à 200 euros par mois
par français c'est le moins que l'on
puisse faire les gens ne s'en sortent
absolument plus faut qu'ils se
réveillent il y a dix millions de
pauvres dans le pays la chose à faire
tout de suite c'est de bloquer les prix
sur les produits de première nécessité
je vous garantis qu'on ne ruinera
personnes en faisant saint joseph
thouvenel instant sans nous dévoiler
évidemment vos préférences politiques
c'est pas le sujet mais aujourd'hui
clairement vous vous sentez que cette
question du pouvoir d'achat ça va être
l'un des thèmes forts et qui aura des
vraies réponses de la part des candidats
des vraies réponses au sérieux en tout
cas de la part des candidats moi
j'attends pas les réponses j'attends les
acteurs quand ils sont élus
tout le monde constate donc que ce soit
l'ensemble de la classe politique qui
vient problèmes de pouvoir d'achat et un
problème d'inflation qui repart y un
problème de prix de l'énergie et
d'autres prix mais il faut aussi se
poser la question des économies qui
peuvent être faits et tout à l'heure je
suis tombé sur un article du nouvel obs
qui date un petit peu mais pas en tant
que ça en trois ans l'état français
dépensé 43 milliards d'euros je me
trompe pas je parle bien de milliards 43
milliards d'euros pour des cabinets
conseils internationaux pour faire des
travaux que les hauts fonctionnaires
peuvent faire alors soit nos
fonctionnaires sont nulles faut pas les
garder un mais 43 milliards d'euros en
trois ans qui ont été dépensés pour des
cabinets internationaux de conseil ça me
scandalise profondément et pour des
tâches qui sont normalement dévolue aux
fonctionnaires ben voilà 43 milliards
d'euros sur trois ans voyez ce qu'on
peut faire comme économie
prescilla le dos qui le mot de la fin
pour vous sur cette campagne qui
s'annonce et les solutions peut-être des
candidats ce que vous restez optimiste
alors j'ai envie de dire
qu'effectivement vu le dernier sondage
de toute confiance des français envers
les politiques qui est de 11 pour cent
ce qui est rien du tout effectivement je
pense que ce qui se dit dans les
programmes de se traduire dans les actes
en fait
restaurer la confiance des gens ça se
fait pas à l'occasion d'une campagne je
pense que là à ce stade les gens
attendent réellement début du vrai
changement dans leur quotidien merci en
tout cas tous les deux jours des photos
venait de près s'il a le dos qui d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
merci